if you want to know where you are you
can check on your phone it listens for
signals from whole constellations of
satellites in orbit and by triangulating
all those signals and using a lot of
maths it works out where you are and
shows you a little dot on a map but how
do the satellites know where they are
there aren't any landmarks in orbit for
them to refer to
if satellites are in a high enough orbit
well away from the atmosphere then they
can predict their position they'll just
keep orbiting in about the same path
there's no atmosphere to slow them down
but that's not precise enough there will
be distortions caused by gravity from
the sun and moon or even from mountain
ranges down on earth so maybe they could
use the other satellite signals like gps
but if they're all relying on each other
that could steadily drift apart from
reality maybe they could track the stars
or the features down on the earth but
that's not precise enough either at some
point something down here on earth has
to look up in the sky and work out the
position precisely and one of those
somethings is hidden away in the
countryside of southern england it looks
like a regular observatory
but it's not looking at the stars we
track man-made satellites in various
orbits doing various jobs they all have
to have special reflectors on that
enables the light to be returned to us
and so we can measure the time of flight
and from the time of flight derive the
distance you send out a very short pulse
of laser light you do that a thousand
times a second each of those shots
because you're using such a tiny short
pulsed laser it's 10 picoseconds long
which is about three millimeters that's
the limitation on your precision so each
shot is about three to four millimeters
precision this station works around the
clock whenever the sky's clear that's
why i'm here today there will be some
genuine observations when the clouds
break but right now i'm not actually
disrupting anything but it does look
significantly better after dark because
it's a laser it's a very specific
wavelength so you can filter and that's
what lets you work in day and night the
main problem with the atmosphere is the
speed of light in a vacuum is a very
well known constant the speed of light
through the atmosphere is variable
according to the mainly the pressure but
also the temperature and humidity so we
measure those things on site as well
there's probably about 35 active
stations scattered around the globe
located predominantly in northern
hemisphere which is a slight problem
from a science point of view you'd like
them evenly distributed all around the
globe there's a couple in australia
which are really important because
they're providing a bulk of the data
from the southern hemisphere ideally
we'd have a more even distribution of
course as the light fades there's one
assumption that we've been working on
throughout this video that the earth the
ground we're standing on doesn't move
and that's not strictly true
in the early days of laser ranging in
the 60s it was the primary method by
which they were deriving those early
measurements of the drift between us and
north america say so you can see
long-term trends like the ice caps
melting and the redistribution of mass
from the ice caps to the equator all the
data goes off to international databases
from all the sites all around the world
anyone any researcher anywhere can go
and grab the international data set the
data from us from australia from north
america from china from russia and can
use that data to derive the orbits and
do the research they need to do thanks
very much to all the team at the space
geodesy facility you can find out more
about them and their work at the link in
the description